[Música]
el partido Colorado se mantiene en el
poder en Paraguay Santiago Peña ya es el
nuevo presidente electo del país tras
vencer con un 43% de los apoyos al
opositor Efraín alegre que lideraba la
concertación nacional
la Unión Europea y América Latina se
necesitan estas fueron las declaraciones
del jefe de la diplomacia europea
josephell quien destacó el ámbito
climático como principal eje de
colaboración entre ambos bloques
aumenta la violencia en Ecuador en la
noche del sábado al domingo 10 personas
fueron asesinadas en un ataque armado en
la ciudad de Guayaquil las autoridades
lo atribuyen a la lucha entre grupos del
crimen organizado que azota el país
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano arrancamos esta
edición en Paraguay el país ya tiene
nuevo presidente electo y se trata de
Santiago Peña el candidato del partido
Colorado Peña se impuso con el 43% de
los votos y logró así mantener en el
poder a la formación colorada conocida
también como asociación nacional
republicana que domina la política del
país de forma casi ininterrumpida desde
hace 70 años el partido sostuvo la
dictadura de Alfredo stroesner y tras el
restablecimiento de la Democracia ha
ganado seis de ocho elecciones generales
escuchemos ahora al que asumirá el poder
en agosto
desigualdades ni injustas asimetrías
sociales tenemos mucho por hacer después
de los últimos años de estancamiento
económico de déficit fiscal con un
preocupante índice desocupados y el
aumento de la pobreza extrema la tarea
que nos espera no es para una sola
persona o solo para un partido y desde
la sede del partido Colorado nuestra
enviada especial a Asunción Valeria
sakone no reporta Cómo se vive esta
nueva Victoria
alegría en la sede del partido Colorado
aquí en Asunción por la victoria holgada
de Santiago Peña sobre su contrincante
Frank alegre que pierde por tercera vez
las elecciones esta vez con un elemento
nuevo la irrupción de paraguayos Cuba el
candidato antisistema que capitalizado
el descontento de una parte de la
población consiguiendo un resultado
espectacular hoy hemos pasado por varios
colegios electorales y personas de
diferentes edades nos decían que no se
sienten representados por ninguno de los
dos partidos hegemónicos y que querían
un cambio sin embargo este cambio no se
ha visto
reflejado en las urnas la mayoría de los
paraguayos ha elegido la continuidad no
solo con el partido Colorado sino
también con el modelo de Horacio
cartesca es el presidente del partido
recordamos que cartes ha sido declarado
corrupto por el gobierno de los Estados
Unidos y que Santiago Peña le ha alabado
en su discurso nada más renunciar su
Victoria todo apunta a que Horacio
Carter seguirá gobernando en la sombra
porque sabemos que Peña es su delfín
también se decían las últimas semanas
que el gobierno de Maiden podría pedir
la extradición de cartes por sus delitos
que también están en el solo
norteamericano sin embargo parece muy
difícil ese escenario ahora es el
momento de celebrar para aquellos
votantes que han elegido al partido
Colorado
Santiago Peña tiene hasta el 15 de
agosto para preparar la transición y
Entonces será el nuevo presidente de
Paraguay
y a continuación repasamos el perfil del
presidente electo Santiago Peña
economista y exministro de Hacienda del
polémico Horacio cartes quien lo avaló
al frente del partido Colorado una de
las formaciones más antiguas de América
Latina Luis Muñoz con los detalles
su bandera la juventud Santiago Peña era
director del Banco Central a los 32 años
y fue el ministro de hacienda más joven
de Paraguay promete crear 500.000
puestos de trabajo en un país de 6,7
millones de personas y en entrevista
para france24 prometió reducir el 30% de
pobreza del país y se va a solucionar se
puede solucionar Y es inaceptable que en
un país tan rico como el Paraguay que
pueda alimentar a 80 millones de
personas en el mundo tengamos personas
que no pueden completar una ración
mínima de alimento Ha logrado la
victoria pese a las diferencias que
mantiene con el saliente presidente
Mario abdo Benítez Peña es visto como el
delfín del expresidente Horacio Garcés
líder del partido Colorado quienes
considerado el mandatario en la sombra y
quien goza de Gran popularidad Pese a
que cartest fue sancionado por Estados
Unidos por corrupción el candidato
Colorado brinda apoyo a quien confió en
él como ministro un pedido todo es que
se defienda que no escatime esfuerzos en
rebatir todas estas acusaciones donde
hasta ahora lastimosamente no ha tenido
la posibilidad de defenderse
pese a los problemas con Estados Unidos
Santiago Peña promete mantener su apoyo
a Taiwán sin embargo en política
internacional ya ha tenido problemas
después de llamar vagos a los argentinos
en el ámbito local ha elogiado la
dictadura de stresner Y ante la
diversidad lgbt o el aborto se sitúa al
lado de la que considera familia
tradicional su gran triunfo mantener la
hegemonía colorada pese a los
pronósticos
y en una entrevista con la agencia Efe
en Colombia El Alto representante de la
Unión Europea para asuntos exteriores y
políticas de seguridad social insistió
en que la Unión Europea y América Latina
se necesitan a pesar de tener una
relación compleja además el jefe de la
diplomacia europea señaló la violencia
Armada como uno de los retos que
enfrenta la región latinoamericana creo
que lo que ha salido a la reunión es que
Europa necesita aliados necesita para
existir en mundo y América Latina tiene
oportunidades que ofrecer y
oportunidades que recibir hemos de
buscar complementariedades evitando los
irritantes de nuestra relación los
grandes problemas del medio ambiente
pero también los problemas intrínsecos
de América Latina la desigualdad la
violencia ha acabado de enterarme de ese
ataque armado en Guayaquil Donde ha
muerto diez personas todavía no puedo
decir de quién ni cómo pero los muertos
están muertos Y eso es una cosa que
primero que hay que lamentar Y en
segundo lugar intentar buscarle una
solución y para eso desde luego Europa
puede contribuir y ampliamos la
información a la que se refería al jefe
de la diplomacia Europea y es que en la
noche del sábado a domingo la ciudad
ecuatoriana de Guayaquil fue escenario
de una Nueva Ola de asesinatos diez
personas murieron y otras tres
resultaron heridas en un ataque armado
la fiscal general del estado cree que se
trata de una lucha de los grupos del
crimen organizado que buscan controlar
el territorio y en particular este
Puerto del Pacífico desde Ecuador
Gustavo Ortega nos amplia
es un fin de semana de asesinatos a
consecuencia de la guerra entre bandas
del narcotráfico aseguró la Policía
Nacional la noche del sábado nuevo
ataque armado ocurrió en un suburbio de
la ciudad de Guayaquil con un saldo que
ya supera la Decena de personas según
anunció la fiscalía general del estado
Guayaquil es el centro de la disputas
entre las bandas del narcotráfico según
la Policía Nacional un grupo de personas
atacó con fusiles a otros que se
encontraban reunidos en un taller
mecánico cinco de los fallecidos tenían
antecedentes penales y una de las
víctimas registraba seis detenciones por
robo el crimen múltiple ocurrió mientras
la ciudad de Guayaquil se encuentra en
medio de un estado de sección y el
gobierno había anunciado medidas contra
la criminalidad hace cuatro días
paralelamente otro ataque armado ocurrió
en la ciudad costera de atacames
siguiendo el mismo patrón según anunció
la Policía Nacional un grupo fuertemente
armado ingresó en un lugar de diversión
nocturna abriendo fuego en contra de los
asistentes las autoridades
responsabilizan de lo sucedido a las
luchas por territorio entre las bandas
del crimen organizado señalando a los
gánsters y a los tiburones bandas
delincuencia organizada en este país
sucede cuando el Consejo de Seguridad
Pública del Estado ha recomendado al
gobierno utilizar armas letales y
aplicar nuevas medidas fuertes contra la
criminalidad y declarar al terrorismo
como amenaza y enfrentar a los grupos
delincuencia organizada por parte de las
fuerzas armadas
y cerramos con cine porque la película
de Super Mario Bros del estudio
universal continúa imbatible en las
taquillas de Estados Unidos y Canadá
donde lideró las ventas de entradas por
cuarto fin de semana consecutivo la
película de animación inspirada en el
famoso juego de Nintendo recaudó más de
mil millones de dólares a nivel Global
en el estreno el 5 de abril
llegamos así al final de esta edición
pero sigan con más información
[Música]